[Music]  my thoughts are with all of those who  did the right thing and for whom this is  a real slap in the face  they made the most unimaginable  heart-wrenching sacrifices  and many were overcome by guilt guilt of  not seeing elderly relatives not going  to funerals or weddings or even seeing  the birth of their own children  but the guilty men are the prime  minister and the chancellor  they've dishonored all of that sacrifice  they've dishonored their office  this is the first time in the history of  our country that a prime minister's been  found to be in breach of the law  and then he lied repeatedly to the  public about it  britain deserves better they have to go